qu'est-ce que le paradis c'est un endroit paisible dans
le ciel
vas-tu au paradis non
pourquoi pas
[Musique]
tu dois être une bonne personne pour aller au
paradis il
y a 10 ans aujourd'hui l'
intelligence artificielle créée pour nous protéger a
fait exploser une ogive nucléaire à Los
Angeles
aussi longtemps  comme l'IA est une menace,
nous n'arrêterons jamais de chasser les copies, c'est
un combat pour notre existence même,
peu importe ce qu'il y a dedans, ils sont sûrs
que quelqu'un entre,
ouais, nous sortons
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
nous sommes les mêmes, nous pouvons  Je n'irai pas au paradis
parce que tu n'es pas bon
et je ne suis pas une personne
ouais c'est une clé
j'en fais un avec le piège
tu es si proche de gagner la guerre,
exécute-la ou nous allons disparaître
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ils'  je viens me chercher à
l'étranger